vodka has a watermelon delivery service
yeah what you do it takes his watermelon
he puts in this back of his red tricycle
and he goes to you and it gives it to
you and when you after he just likes my
thank yous yeah yeah how many you guys
have seen the show Criminal Minds
oh I auditioned several times really
yeah what oh yeah which character a lot
of the different guest stars they so
there's different guest stars every show
because it centers around one criminal
every time yeah so they it's usually
people's first TV show that they get on
because oh there's they need some in all
these new cases I just want this one
there's like a crime law and order type
yeah yeah yeah so happy you know so the
question did you watch it no oh I did
but you audition I watched what should
the enough episodes to know what I was
auditioning for like the tone of the
show I didn't like watch it regularly be
thankful that you didn't get the part
what because California authorities are
now suing the entire team of Criminal
Minds
what what do you mean like even the
actors even everybody the producer
actors can't get protected by the Union
yeah because the companies behind
criminal criminal criminal minds we're
stealing stories there was for sexual
harassment oh [ __ ] yes so the director
photography so the director of
photography for those of you there don't
know is the guy that's in charge of the
[ __ ] lighting the camera placements
and all that stuff
he has gone I guess he's on the Sean set
he's been harassing a lot of different
actors that's not the job for him that's
for the casting director true the
casting director is supposed to harass
people on a casting couch oh she was a
woman every time I went but I mean I
guess that doesn't stop ah that's why
you didn't get the part man you should
have [ __ ] giving up the pan that's
true there was a couch at the Julie on
it no that's real messed up that's true
mm-hmm so this guy yeah his name is
Gregory st. John's
and oh I'm really - sounds like soda
Gregory st. John so disgusting oh yeah
sound like he runs a church it does
think yeah it's like a fancy clothing
line or yeah could I go to st. John's we
had the companies that are involved in
the lawsuit now though is Walt Disney
Company Oh
ABC substitutes
CBS Studios and various individuals
there's a lot of studios involved on so
Criminal Minds is a pretty big big deal
I guess a lot of entities involved and
basically what this mouse is he okay Oh
true Mickey Mouse he was one of the
episodes
Yanzhi yeah st. John's the DP he is
notorious for being on set for I guess
slapping butts stuff like that and I
guess you wouldn't be safe in this in
this instance what he wouldn't like my
but what is that what you say he likes a
purpose he prefers a certain gender oh I
see yes and it's mainly from all the
names I'm getting it's all male actors
are getting there but slab for the Kevin
Spacey dance mints ah yeah Kevin Spacey
type stuff was just a baseball like a
she's a lot like dudes asses you know
I'm saying just has like camaraderie
type [ __ ] privy maybe this woman had a
slap in a cup yeah whoa proper settings
yeah true cuz you know wasn't it the
rock who came out and explained his like
sexual harassment area no he was at some
something like smooshy Hollywood it was
during the me to movement that's when he
came out with it yeah so this like
Hollywood producer I guess came up to
him and like cupped his dick in front of
his wife whoa like Terry Crews with his
wife and Sal just came up someone like
grabbed his dick I'd be so scared to do
that you're just like to take cruise
yeah
I mean and Halu producer must be really
powerful yeah and the theory in his own
right right yeah because he's like you
want the job
yeah or I could [ __ ] end your career
if you don't like what I'm doing to you
right now I guess hmm that's scary yeah
but yeah so this guy he's like slapping
butts and I mean it's really vague as to
what he's actually doing on set but it
seems to be all men hmm crew members and
actors alike on set that have you know
corroborated on the fact that this guy
is sexually harassing everyone and the
reason why the whole show is being sued
is the fact that a lot of the producers
and a lot of executives knew about the
harassment there were a lot of
complaints filed by the actors and crew
members and nothing was done it's like a
Catholic Church yeah come soon is that
the fact gentle winds nothing was done
they're thinking like they're just and
further they're enabling it now at this
point so the the show wrapped up the
entire I think the whole show is done
now back in February and now this whole
story is starting to take steam and
snowball yeah the who's gonna do the
lighting like st. John's once he get to
trouble I looked at my I was kind of
curious as to like is this guy like the
big deal in Hollywood that's why he's
protected I looked him up and aside from
being a DP which is a really major role
in a movie set right
he's only been our DP on a few shows and
including this show and then he was just
a first AC kind of assistant guy for the
camera department on other stuff this
shows been around forever so maybe he
produced a certain look for that show
that they didn't want to they needed him
there yeah yeah we need you yeah cuz you
think like why wouldn't they just fire
on get another DP right hmm yeah was he
that important I don't know I mean I
feel like maybe they're just trying to
like hide it to protect themselves to
and protect all because if it becomes
real it hurts the show though yeah
true or could help the show if they got
a new guy in there and it's like our old
guy was a piece of [ __ ] in this guy's
better stand we don't stand for this we
don't wait so who's prosecuting the the
City of Cal California's Department of
Fair Employment and housing hmm so I
guess there was enough people that was
like this shit's being unreported
yeah I think the actors they were
harassed yeah what surprises me is the
fact that this didn't come out come to
light during the me to movement cuz this
shows ya long-running I'm so surprised
that sag didn't do anything cuz they're
supposed to protect the actors to like
they have their own Department that like
if if you have a problem on set you can
call and be like this shit's going down
right makes me uncomfortable sag is the
Screen Actors Guild it's a union for
people in the entertainment I'm not
saying it could probably do something
but if it's like this point maybe that
nobody even spoke up maybe he says they
were reporting to but I wonder who they
reporting there are being hushed I think
it could be like internal yeah maybe
they didn't try sag maybe didn't they
try outside but what if they tried like
internally and felt helpless well maybe
that guy has connections that like could
prevent people from getting future work
or something I feel like some people
might even be scared to report just cuz
you know how powerful they are
yeah well cuz like like you said it's a
bunch of like new like stories and
actors right so maybe this guy's been
here for so long that people that felt
like they were new didn't wanna say
anything cuz like okay I could easily
get let go from this [ __ ] right
well like damn what does he I want to
know exactly more details like what was
he doing to make people so uncomfortable
cuz I don't want to do just like
whatever right I don't know what was
happening yeah and also though like I
think guys um straight guys are so
unfulfilled I'm familiar with being
sexually harassed that like they don't
even know what to make sense of it right
and I heard that like statistically
guys are less likely to report sexual
harassment than women hmm it's also I
think it's uh it's you kind of seem
lesser to do it like you're supposed to
be a madman stand up and it's not that
big of a deal to do it you know
yeah just brush it off it's not a big
deal yeah because that was a whole thing
about Terry Crews when he came out with
his story people were like what the [ __ ]
you Terris mind you just sucked his dude
in the face like why did gonna supported
him yeah no one supported him and he's
like bro I felt violated I feel like I
didn't have power in the situation like
me being like a big buff dude has
nothing to do with that yeah yeah I
could be as gangster as hell but if the
president [ __ ] jacks me off he jacked
me off man like saying he did that and
then now that guy that he got in trouble
all his friends are like we're never
gonna put territories on yeah yeah
that's exactly what it is yeah you know
for me like I've been for so many years
and like Nikki I'm all on this year like
we want to be a part of this Hollywood
scene we want to be a part of the movie
industry and get into it but like when
like the me to movement happens and my
stories like this come out and I'm like
[ __ ] man like [ __ ] feels dirty I mean
you're definitely
it looks very disgusting yeah I feel
like there's also people that have like
I guess maybe a more of cleaner
experience or just the companies that
they work with so I feel like it's not I
mean we hear a lot of these crazy
stories and this is just any time
there's people in power in politics you
know there's just people we're gonna
abused it so I still want to be a part
of Hollywood I think what's cool if
Netflix it's the instead of like you
have to be in the actual Hollywood realm
Netflix made it possible where you can
be like independent companies and they
kind of outsource which is kind of cool
yeah there's less of a vibe of you gotta
play the Hollywood game to get in the
room now
saying now that everything's switched
especially from like you know social
media shed and people like us like
coming up on YouTube and there's like
all these like Netflix and Amazon and
like everybody's a different streaming
company it's like you know the game is
totally different yeah yeah so now
California is seeking compensate Tori
you see though that Satori components at
ornament payments and I should read more
punitive damages plus injunctive
declaratory sounded out wherever that
[ __ ] that word the [ __ ] that means
yeah there we go my name's eclipse
literate yeah declare wait so who
whenever they collect and find money
like I want to know where the [ __ ] does
it go does it go into the pockets of the
people who charge does it go into like
yeah is it a class act the hospital like
where does it go go so like the
California bankers all right and they
use it so the state takes it wait also
the time the fines yeah I just goes to
the state wait what do you mean physical
actors and stuff yeah I would think that
would go to the personal people they're
just representing them harm in a fair
employment I was just thinking about my
traffic ticket yeah cuz that's all a lot
of cities actually make money yeah is
through traffic tickets like certain
towns on like you know like when we go
on road trips right they have no economy
in that town and that's one way that the
the city can make money so the the cops
all they do is [ __ ] chase people down
and give them tickets yeah like when you
cross into Vegas yes that's a speed
Travis got like three tickets going in
today yes
I think like that's what converted me to
only flying because the cost of the
speeding ticket plus gas we weigh more
than go back to court if you want to go
to Cornell go back to court over there
and they make it so hard for you to do
they don't give you a notice that was
like hey remember you have to pay this
ticket they just like you have to
remember to go to war in California now
they don't even tell you how much you
cause they just say hey we're gonna mail
it out yeah well they were they don't
they write something to you they just
basically like it's it's
nothing really they'll give you the
ticket and it doesn't necessarily say
how much it is until like your court
date or they sent you this because it's
basically they're gonna have to do their
research and see like the fine dictates
on how good your driving record is so
it's not fine anymore it's peaceful
that's called a so then like that it's
not a flat rate it's like if you have
you've been on good behavior
yeah it could be less that's cool is it
cool is it man if they feel like being a
dick they can too because one time I got
pulled over for speeding and then I had
an air freshener hanging he got me for
yeah obstruction of my view but a death
tinted window didn't get you for so many
things if they want to I'm saying just
throw it in there and I got pulled over
I got a ticket for going like less than
five miles above this above the speed
limit because they're just like if
they're at Sur meeting unquote oh yeah
they're meeting a quota if there has
certain times in the month mark cop
friend says that there's enough laws
written to where majority of people are
violating something right that if they
want to they can find it but usually he
says most cops the way that they do it
is they use that as a way to get into
like someone who might have a warrant or
crime it goes like there are dicks out
there that just pretty much like oh I
just need to write this out so I'm gonna
give you something
mmm I'm like damn dude that's too much
there's racial profiling - all right do
guys like my old car had I bought it
from this chick and she like had it all
like the she had like the chrome wheels
and she had like the posters yeah she
like it was all decked out yeah it's all
gangster and I got pulled over so much
Drive like this and did you have
eyebrows they couldn't see me when I'm
pulling me over they roll the window
down and I have got out of tickets
because they were like well you know how
about you were oh I just be safer
because they were I think they were just
profiling like you're not the black girl
I expected or them or the you know
Mexican but did you show your boobies I
did not show my boobies why was I did
you like fluttering fluttering like I'm
just gonna go see my dad right now I
tried the the diarrhea thing went on
when I got pulled over and they do
believe that [ __ ] ever I was like yo
what did you I know it wasn't you I
forgot that terrible Dario about to
shoot myself he's like no if you had
area you would have pulled into that
McDonald's back there and sit him mean
by yeah he's I just [ __ ] in that one so
I know [ __ ] your pants yeah oh yeah I
think that I should Saul real that
profiling stuff oh yeah they do it oh
yeah
[Music]
[Music]